[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au revoir les enfants
nous avons eu une rude journée et bien
nounours tu ne descend pas voir tes amis
nicolaï et oui tu nounours ça par
exemple il n'était là il ya cinq minutes
il est peut-être tombé du nuage nounours
nounours où es tu oh quelle aventure
nous avons perdu nounours je vais me
renseigner auprès de nicolas et de
pimprenelle mon petit téléphone rouge là
à l'eau
halo 1 prenait lé nicolas bonsoir à
l'eau petit marc johnson au non il est
pas là non il est pas foutu
il est pavé toi sur ton nuage attend on
va voir la fenêtre sur le balcon
non aux outils de cette image on
souhaiterait caucase
[Musique]
allo nicolas
tu as bien chercher pour temps et vous
les enfants
vous n'avez pas vu nounours bon alors
personne n'a vu une ourse parce que
j'entends mes démons nuage
c'est sûrement une petite souris allons
montrer vous petite souris je ne suis
pas une petite souris aux trop gros
coquin tu t'étais cacher ce taux pour
férus de blow pas preneur et en y
collant bas pourront jeter ce en vue de
les voir on le chope à non monsieur le
coquin qui fait des blagues
il est trop tard vous n'avez plus le
temps d'aller voir youtube ou dix
minutes pas trop dit leur bonne nuit au
téléphone il demain tu descendras vic
les voir un grand moment aux lots issus
nounours août ne faut nous et on fera
aussi blague je vous ai bien eus quand
même à demain les enfants au
je vous embrasse
au hall aux atomes ou au dos d'une bonne
nuit les enfants allons en route gros
blagueur une seconde pas trop quand je
tourne le dos à voile a eu lieu
[Musique]
pour deux nuits à deux mains
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]